an award-winning musician had thousands
of dollars worth of equipment stolen
here in las vegas the performer was here
from louisiana at sam's town hotel and
gambling hall off boulder highway when
he says his trailer was taken madison
kimbrough joins us live tonight with the
story madison
musician terrence simeon was performing
in vegas last week when he had all of
his equipment stolen from his trailer at
the parking lot right here at the sam's
town hotel and gambling hall what
happened while the musician and his band
mates were sleeping as security footage
from the casino shows a u-haul truck
towing their trailer away in the middle
of the night unfortunately you can't see
the u-haul's license plate or the
identity of the people involved from
guitars to keyboards accordions to cds
and merchandise 35 thousand dollars
worth of equipment was gone overnight
simeon recalls one instrument that was
very precious to him and his bandmates
especially now due to what's going on
overseas these reports were
worn
on kids all over the world including
russia and ukraine we love vegas we love
the people of vegas you know we don't
blame them for this but we just you know
this is this is was a shock i mean you
know to wake up one morning and
all that we had to make our living with
all of our tools were gone
[Music]
their band terrance simeon and the
zydeco experience had to cancel the rest
of their tour because they didn't have
enough equipment to play with terence
has filed a police report and the hope
is that their trailer will be found with
all the items still inside simeon's band
was playing creole music from louisiana
for several schools across the valley
and also performed at the water street
plaza in henderson we have a link to
their gofundme page up on our website
attached to this story if you would like
to help reporting live near sam's town
madison kimbrough live local now